let's say that we have some function f
of x right over here and let me graph an
arbitrary f of x
so that's my y-axis
that is my x-axis and maybe f of x looks
something like that and what i want to
do is i want to approximate f of x with
a taylor polynomial centered around
centered around x is equal to a so this
is the x-axis this is the y-axis so i
want a taylor polynomial centered around
there and we've seen how this works the
taylor polynomial comes out of the idea
that
for all of the derivatives up to and
including the degree of the polynomial
those derivatives of that polynomial
evaluated at a should be equal to the
derivatives of our function evaluated a
and that polynomial evaluated a should
also be equal to that function of value
of a so our polynomial our taylor
polynomial approximation would look
something like this
so
i'll call it p of x
and sometimes you might see a subscript
a big n there to say it's an nth degree
approximation and sometimes you'll see
something like this
sometimes you'll see something like n
comma a to say it's an nth degree
approximation centered at a actually
i'll write that right now maybe we might
lose it if we have to keep writing it
over and over but you should assume that
it is an nth degree polynomial centered
at a it's going to look like this it is
going to be
f of a
plus
f prime of a
times x minus a
plus
f prime prime of a times x minus a
squared over either you could write 2 or
2 factorial they're the same value i'll
write 2 factorial you could write a
divided by 1 factorial over here if you
like and then plus
you go to the third derivative of f
at a times x minus a to the third power
i think you see where this is going over
3 factorial and you keep going i'll go
to this line right here all the way to
your nth degree term which is the nth
derivative of f evaluated at a
times x minus a to the n
over
n factorial and this polynomial right
over here this nth degree polynomial
center today it's definitely f of a is
going to be the same or f or p of a is
going to be same thing as f of a and you
can verify that because all of these
other terms have an x minus a here so if
you put an a in the polynomial all of
these other terms are going to be 0.
you'll have p of a is equal to f of a
let me write that down p of a is equal
to
p of a is equal to f of a
and so it might look something like this
and it's going to fit the curve better
the more of these terms that we actually
have so it might look something like
this i'm trying my best
try my best
to
to show what it might look like
and what i want to do in this video so
this is all review i have this
polynomial that's approximating this
function the more terms i have the
higher degree of this polynomial the
better that it will fit this curve the
further that i get away from a but what
i want to do in this video is think
about if we can bound how good it's
fitting how good it's fitting this
function as we move away from a so what
i want to do is define a remainder
function or sometimes i've seen some
textbooks call it an error function and
i'm going to call this let me call this
let me call this i'll just call it an
error so let me just just so you're
consistent with all the different
notations you might see in a book some
people will call this a remainder
function and sometimes we'll write a
remainder function for an nth degree
polynomial centered at a
sometimes you'll see this as an error
function
some the the error function is sometimes
avoided because it looks like expected
value from probability but you'll see
this often this is e for error
e for error r for remainder and
sometimes they'll also have the
subscripts over there like that and what
we'll do is we'll just define this
function to be the difference between
the p the difference between f of x and
our approximation of f of x for any
given x so it's really just going to be
doing the same colors it's going to be f
of x
minus
minus p of x minus p of x where this is
an nth degree polynomial nth degree
polynomial centered at a so for example
if someone were to ask you or if you
wanted to visualize what what are they
talking about if they're saying the
error of this nth degree polynomial
center today when we are at x is equal
to b
what is this thing equal to or how
should you think about this well if b is
right over here if b is right over here
so the error of b is going to be f of b
minus the polynomial at b so f of b
there the polynomial's right over there
so it'll be this distance right over
here so if you measure the error at a if
you measured the error at a it would
actually be zero because the polynomial
and the function are the same there f of
a is equal to p of a so the error at a
is equal to zero let me actually write
that down because that's an interesting
property it'll help us bound it
eventually so let me write that error
the error function at a and for the rest
of this video you can assume that i that
i could write a subscript this is for
the nth degree polynomial centered at a
i'm just going to not write that every
time just to save ourselves a little bit
of time in writing to keep my my hand
fresh so the area at a is equal to
f of a
minus p of a and once again i won't
write the sub n sub a you can assume it
this is an nth degree polynomial center
today and these two things are equal to
each other so this is going to be equal
to 0 and we see that right over here the
distance between the two functions is 0
there now let's think about something
else let's think about let's think about
what the derivative
let's think about what the derivative
of the error function evaluated a is
well that's going to be the derivative
of our function at a minus the
derivative of our the first derivative
of our polynomial at a
and if we assume that this has more than
if this is higher than degree 1 we know
that these derivatives are going to be
the same at a you can try to take the
first derivative here if you take the
first derivative of this whole mess and
this is actually why taylor polynomials
are so useful is that up to and
including the degree of the polynomial
when you evaluate the derivatives of
your polynomial at a they're going to be
the same as the derivatives of the
function at a and that's what starts to
make it a good approximation but if you
took a derivative here
this term right here will disappear
it'll go to zero i'll cross it out for
now this term right over here will just
be f prime of a and then all of these
other terms are going to be left with
some type of an x minus a in them and so
when you evaluated a all the terms with
an x minus a disappear because you have
an a minus a on them this one already
disappeared and you're literally just
left with
p of a p prime of a will equal to f
prime of a and we've seen that before
so let me write that so because we know
that p prime of a is equal to f prime of
a
when we evaluate when you evaluate the
error function the derivative of the
error function at a that also is going
to be equal to zero
and this general property right over
here is true up to and including n so
let me write this down
so
we already know that p of a is equal to
f of a we already know that p prime of a
is equal to f prime of a this really
comes straight out of the definition of
the taylor polynomials and this is going
to be true all the way until the nth
derivative of our polynomial is going
evaluated at a not everywhere just
evaluated a is going to be equal to the
nth derivative of our function
of our function evaluated at a so what
that tells us is that we could keep
doing this with the error function all
the way
to the nth derivative of the error
function evaluated at a is going to be
equal to well that's just going to be
the nth derivative
of f evaluated at a minus the nth
derivative of our polynomial evaluated a
and we already said that these are going
to be equal to each other up to the nth
derivative when we evaluate them at a so
these are all going to be equal to 0. so
this is an interesting property and it's
also going to be useful when we start to
try to bound this error function and
that's the whole point of where i'm
going with this video and probably the
next video is we're going to try to
bound it so we know how good of an
estimate we are we have especially as we
go further and further from where we are
centered from where our approximation is
centered now let's think about when we
take a derivative beyond that so let's
think about what happens when we take
the n plus one derivative so let me
what's a good place to write well i can
i have some screen real estate right
over here so what happens if i take the
what is the n plus one
derivative of our of our error function
and not even if i'm just evaluating
today if i just say generally the error
function e of x what's the n plus one
derivative of it well it's going to be
the n plus 1 the derivative of our
function
is going to be the n plus 1 the
derivative of our function minus the n
plus 1 derivative
minus the n plus 1 derivative of our
we're not just evaluated a here either
let me write it x there
our function minus i'm just i'm
literally just taking the the the n plus
one the derivative of both sides of this
equation right over here so it's
literally the n plus one the derivative
of our function minus the n plus one the
derivative of our nth degree polynomial
of our nth degree polynomial the n plus
one derivative of our nth degree
polynomial i could once again i could
write an n here i could write an a here
to show it's an nth degree centered at a
now what is the n plus 1 derivative of
an nth degree polynomial
and if you if you if you want some hints
take the second derivative of take the
second derivative of y is equal to x
it's a first degree polynomial take the
second derivative you're going to get 0.
take the take the third derivative of y
is equal to x squared the first
derivative is 2x the second derivative
is 2 the third derivative is 0.
in general if you take an n plus 1
derivative of an nth degree polynomial
and you could prove it for yourself you
could even prove it generally but i
think it might make a little sense to
you
it's going to be equal to zero
it is going to be equal to zero so this
thing right here this is an n plus one
derivative of an nth degree polynomial
this is going this is going to be equal
to zero so the
so the n plus one
let me write this over here the n plus
one
derivative of our error function or a
remainder function we could call it is
equal to the n plus one
is equal to the n plus one derivative of
our function
and so what we could do now and we'll
probably have to continue this in the
next video is figure out at least can we
bound this can we bound this and if we
are able to bound this if we're able to
figure out an upper bound on its
magnitude so actually what we want to do
is we want to bound its overall
magnitude we want to bound its absolute
value if we can determine that it is
less than or equal to some value m so if
we can actually bound it maybe we can do
a little bit of calculus we could keep
integrating it and maybe we can go back
to the original function and bound that
in some way if we do know some type of
bound like this over here so i'll take
that up in the next video